if you wanted to download new features
to your phone you can tap a few buttons
press download and hey presto new
features but if you wanted to update the
features in your car say add more
horsepower you'd probably have to take
it back to the dealership or even buy a
new car but now that's changing and
there's a big reason why we will give
our customers the ability to upgrade
their vehicles in real time that's
stilantis the makers of jeep dodge and
chrysler to name a few saying that soon
drivers will be able to download
upgrades like additional horsepower
direct to their car it means that in the
future your car could come pre-loaded
with add-ons that you pay to turn on
whenever you choose stellantis and gm
have both said that they expect software
and services to generate tens of
billions of dollars in revenue by the
end of the decade and to get there
they're investing billions into
developing new software we will prove
how disruptive the auto sector can be
they have a huge challenge in terms of
persuading car drivers to move off their
phones onto the automotive interfaces so
why is software suddenly such a big deal
for legacy car manufacturers let's jump
in
one key reason that automakers are
betting so heavily on software is that
it expands their revenue streams so
unless you bought your car from one of
the new startups that sell direct to the
consumer there's a strong chance you
bought it from a dealership
and the day you purchased it was their
main chance to upsell you on extra
features job began selling the new car
and as many accessories as he could so
the deal would get closer to a
reasonable figure but by delivering
updates over the internet customers can
buy or even subscribe to new features
whenever they want and that gives
automakers a potentially unlimited
window to upsell the hope is they can
make ongoing revenue streams based on
monthly subscriptions so they don't
actually have to find a new customer
every single day of the year in order to
make their revenues
but in order to get customers to pay for
subscriptions they're going to have to
offer something competitive via their
software and that's where automakers
have struggled in the past
car production works on these five seven
year cycles whereas software and phones
work on two-year cycles historically it
just meant that the phones just very
rapidly left years ahead of car software
and infotainment here's an example this
is my car's built-in infotainment system
it comes with radio and voice memos and
i rarely ever use it because every time
my wife and i get in the car we plug our
phones in using apple carplay or android
auto and that gives us access to the
latest versions of things like google
maps and waze for free and we're not
alone a study this year found that over
half of those surveyed preferred apple
or google's car software over their
car's inbuilt system so now automakers
are looking to change that our strategy
is to disconnect the hardware and the
software cycles to create a product that
can evolve naturally and regularly their
main strategy is to go far deeper under
the hood where smartphone makers can't
go hey siri can you give me some more
horsepower
sorry i can't start or stop the
horsepower
stalantis recently announced that
dojoness would soon be able to do
exactly that download software that
unlocks more horsepower to selected
models and polstar who is jointly owned
by volvo and parent company gili have
also said that you can download an
update that gives more horsepower to
their electric polestar 2. the upgrade
costs around 1 100 and so far is only
available in parts of europe but it
doesn't just stop at engine power
automakers have been testing
subscription packages for everything
from heated seats to smarter headlights
to automated parking gm recently
announced that its forthcoming altify
software platform could in the future
offer services like identifying the
driver through facial recognition and
automatically starting the engine you
know because this
such a burden
it's also said that ultify could
potentially be used to let drivers
subscribe on the fly to gm's advanced
driver assistance system called
supercruise
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i'm pretty sure i've heard that
somewhere before
because there's a company that's already
letting customers subscribe to its
driving assistance software
tesla the company lets drivers subscribe
to its full self-driving package which
offers a suite of driver assistance
functions for ten thousand dollars flat
or around two hundred dollars a month
all tesla's being produced right now
have this computer see the latest
tesla's come out of the box with all
those features built into the vehicle
but they only turn on if you pay for
them tesla doesn't break out revenue or
profits for its full self-driving
software but investors belief in its
automation technology is part of what
helped transform the company into the
world's most valuable automaker for
other automakers to follow suit it means
that every car they ship out will pretty
much have to be a top of the range model
loaded with hardware that drivers may
never opt into exactly what they end up
building into the cars is is about that
calculation can we assume that 25
percent of people will have this turned
on and therefore that will be worth it
for us to build it into the car already
it could all work out but it remains
unproven even if automakers can find the
right combination of hardware software
and pricing to create competitive
subscription packages it's still unclear
whether they'll be able to move quickly
enough to generate the billions that
they're forecasting after all while gm
and stalantis say they're going to be
rolling out more of their connected cars
over the next few years steven says it
could be a decade until there's enough
of them out there to give these
automakers a meaningful software
business that's almost 15 years away and
a lot can happen in 15 years after all
the iphone is only 14 years old and
foxconn who make the iphone are
developing their own car and google are
pushing to deeper integrate with
automakers so if legacy car
manufacturers want to get a slice of the
automotive software business they might
have to step on the gas
hey if you're interested in tesla's full
self-driving beta then check out my
video here and as always if you're
interested in the future of how we might
be getting from a to b then don't forget
to subscribe see you soon